bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour parler de cette institution des 26
heures restitué hier par la france au
bénin ils sont arrivés au bénin a priori
ce matin brice qui nous quand est-ce que
c'est accueillis au pays où ils vont
finir ses oeuvres
bonjour à tout le monde c'est heureux
selon ont recueilli à l'aéroport
international cardinal bernardin gantin
à 15 heures aujourd'hui par des familles
royales
le citoyen lambda
toutes les personnes qui meurent dans
vie de
récupérer ou de d'accueillir c'est ses
vingt six objets d'art
qu'on attendait si longtemps après après
l'aéroport où il pas une cérémonie et ça
se passera par la suite à la présidence
du du bénin donc il y aura une liesse
populaire
derrière le camion qui transportera elle
est née bien royaux de l'aéroport à la
présidence oui aura il y aura une
cérémonie d'accueil et d'insertion dans
le patrimoine national
pendant oui
oui pendant ces 16 ces objets resteront
à la présidence pour une période
d'acclimatation de deux mois avant
d'être orientés à ouidah au niveau de la
maison du gouverneur dans
le port portugais où la population
pourra facilement avoir visité
contempler pendant une période de trois
ans et après ça cependant ces trois ans
le musée dame aux mets de l'épopée des
amazones et des rois du temps humain dès
que ce sera construit après trois ans
ces objets d'un qui diront oui lamoureux
à bout mais julien volper on parle de 26
pièces des trésors royaux d'abomey
qu'est ce qu'est ce que représentent ces
pièces
bonjour d'abord eu que ça représente à
quel point de vue auprès
du point de vue de l'importance
historique pour le bénin est également
au niveau de ses collections sont
emblématiques effectivement de la
fournit les pièces de la collection un
choix d'amédée donne est donc ça
représente l'intégralité de la
collection d'autres qui étaient
conservés au musée du quai branly
complètement lié donc à la compagne du
dahomey
1194 donc on peut les considérer comme
des pièces historiques ok si toriques de
valeur assez assez varié à parce que
dans 80 des pièces très grand coach
royaux l'e tron il faut voir que dans
l'ensemble cet objet s'agit notamment de
viol a médiatisé
donc vous voyez un enfant comme très
disparates d'objets
comment comment est-ce qu'ils ont été
choisis ces objets pourraient être
restitués
ils ont été choisis on va tenir à 20
centimes littéralement c'est une
décision politique c'est avant tout une
décision présidentielle des choses qui
étaient déjà presque acté avant même but
et du rapport que ta voix
l'idée de deux procès de collection qui
était un ensemble et je crois que ça
s'est arrêté là comme des symboles aussi
été kate et william par le présent
d'arrêter
bri qui joue le haut doubs 16h c'est
aussi une aubaine pour le tourisme
naturellement c'est une aubaine pour le
tourisme au bénin donc la plupart des
mini noah qui n'ont pas qui pendant
longtemps n'ont pas pu avoir accès à ces
oeuvres d'art qui était qui n'était pas
le porter parce que en france n'y va pas
en france qu'il veut mais qu'ils
pouvaient et donc la lune monsieur tout
le monde peut se
rendre
au musée pour pouvoir les contempler et
aussi à l'extérieur les les amoureux de
l'art et de la culture peuvent quitter
la france en tout cas l'europe
l'amérique un peu partout pour venir
découvrir ses yeux et ça fait un peu
plus à gagner pour le bénin je viens
voltaire il ya encore 90 mille objets
d'art dans les dans les musées ou dans
les collections publiques en france
est-ce que ce premier pas en tout cas
cette première institution peut ouvrir
la voie à d'autres restitution
d'ailleurs pas qu'en france
il ya quelqu'un tu peux faire les
collections nationales fait je suis
conservateur même sujet initial titre
personnel
en belgique ce cas-là parler pour les
collectes française est-ce que ça ouvre
la porte à d'autres institutions oui
centre et à entendre récemment à
déclarations encore en encore une fois
il a terral de monsieur mais le
maquereau qui a parlé d'un tombeau pas
côte d'ivoire la meute en beau parleur
et briller par exemple en europe on l'a
eu d'autres catherine en europe on a
d'autres cas de figure par exemple on a
aussi le cas avec avec l'allemagne
l'allemagne qui a annoncé récemment le
retour prochain de pièces de bénéfices
donc bénéfique ça concerne même site et
j'ai rien et donc d'un partenariat qu
nigeria pour des retours de pièges c'est
d'ailleurs le chef de la diplomatie
allemande heiko maas excepté un moyen de
réparer le passé colonial allemand est
très amusant dans le temps pour
l'allemagne que l'allemagne n'a jamais
colonisé le nigeria et donc l'allemagne
pour a prôné restait en fait de
restitution retour décide de ne pas
travailler avec une de ses anciennes
colonies comme le cameroun par exemple
mais avec le nigeria s'il peut
s'expliquer dans le cadre du nigeria
parce que le nigeria est le premier
partenaire économique actuelle du
l'allemagne pour l'afrique de l'ouest
donc il n'y a pas que des cons
alors oui ce qu'il vous ne lisiez la
population se réjouit de cette
restitution et dans le même temps elle
accuse la france de ne pas
rendre assez d'oeuvre
naturellement parce que ce n'est pas
seulement vingt six oeuvres qui ont été
emportés comme bien des guerres en son
temps et c'est plusieurs milliers donc
c'est déjà d'abord un beau début c'est
pour ça la population d'abord contente
de la restitution du cv 6e mais attend
que la france fasse plus que ça
le problème julien voltaire c'est
l'inventaire comment répertorier les
oeuvres qui ont été pillés est-ce qu'on
ait une idée précise d'ailleurs de ce
qui a été volé notamment sur le
continent africain il ya aussi
d'amérique latine et j'en passe comment
est ce que laissait inventaire peuvent
être faites
encore une fois que de parler de la
question des collections nationales fait
jeter comme a précisé qu'on parle
toujours des collections puisque
discussions patrimoine et au roi tu le
fais au quotidien point de vue des
collections muséales européenne il faut
savoir aussi c'est des choses qui
passent sur le marché de la et puisqu'on
parle du bénin ici je veux rappeler
qu'en mars 2009 et une grande vente aux
enchères que c'était 7 en france la
vente alors où il ya eu plusieurs objets
une vingtaine d'objets qui ont été
proposés à la vente des objets
historiques est aussi celui qui était à
la campagne d'abomey qu à ce moment là
il ya une action première de l'ambassade
béninoise pour demander le rachat de ces
piètres et quand ces pièces de la maison
devancé de deux vendeurs ont accepté et
pour les 28 objet la somme de 24 euros
étaient demandées dont 24 novembre on
est à moins de 10 euros par objet au
début la chose a été acceptée et
seulement là bas ça n'a dit bah
finalement non c'est trop cher on les
prend pas les objets ont été rachetés on
peut se rassurer ils ont été rachetés
par la critique de marchands parisiens
qui possède un musée privé au bénin et
petit musée de l'art et adt et les
objets seront exposés là bas et pour
tout ça pour dire qu'il ya aussi des
moyens de constituer des collections qui
se font aussi par la terre par l'achat
d'objets et que par exemple aux quatre
vents alors je
sais qu'à l'ambassade béninois était
complètement d'exister de quelque chose
lequel s'était aventure
merci beaucoup je viens vous le père
pour autre éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes docteur en histoire de l'art merci
à vous brise qui nous journalistes
spécialistes du bénin